hotter for longer more often and in more
unusual places heat waves are being
intensified by climate change as people
across asia and europe suffer the
consequences of record high temperatures
scientists say new attribution studies
prove heat waves are driven by man-made
temperature increases we have so many
more heat waves
we have heat waves in in europe and we
have heat waves in saudi arabia at the
moment we have heat waves in china right
now we have heat waves in the us and
this is exactly what what sort of the
review paper also shows we just see the
frequency of heat waves has gone up so
much so this is this is very much we
don't need to do attribution studies on
every single one of them because we know
already that climate change is a key
driver here
as extreme weather events from scorching
temperatures to torrential rains cause
widespread death and destruction
researchers tried to identify the
influence of climate change on
individual weather events going back 20
years in the last three months monsoon
rains unleashed disastrous flooding in
bangladesh killing dozens and displacing
four and a half million people while
prolonged drought has left millions on
the brink of famine in east africa
while the same analyses of these events
don't draw a direct link with climate
change it is still a factor we know
generally things like rainfall are
getting more extreme
that's kind of generally true but it's a
little more
nuanced
but we have seen across the world
a lot of serious and very damaging
floods become more likely due to climate
change
what the study highlights is that
despite heat waves killing 157 000
people worldwide between 2000 and 2020
some countries still don't monitor them
or even agree how to define them there's
not enough information coming from lower
and middle income countries and the
economic impact on productivity
infrastructure and property often goes
unmeasured and health consequences
unnoticed
in tokyo currently experiencing the
worst heat wave since 1875
electricity demand is outstripping
supply threatening power outages
but while climate change is a key driver
it's not the reason many of these
extreme weather events turn into
catastrophes say scientists
but high poverty rates poor
infrastructure and crumbling healthcare
systems which must factor into future
disaster prevention strategies charlie
angela al jazeera